Ho, ho, ho!
Merry Christmas, Happy Holidays, and Freaky
Festivus to you all from your good friends
at SCP Explained!
Deck the halls with boughs of SCP-407-induced
plant life, because today we’re gonna hit
you with the kind of Christmas Cheer you just
can’t contain!
Hang your stockings, pour a tall glass of
eggnog, and slip on your most hideous yuletide
sweater, because this is A Keter Kinda Christmas!
We’ve discussed Christmas anomalies both
in-depth and in passing on this channel before,
like SCP-4666, the positively terrifying Yule
Man, whose ritual Christmastime slayings strike
fear into the hearts of families everywhere.
Or SCP-784, Christmas Cheer, a community where
it’s Christmas every day, and anyone who
refuses to show the proper spirit is dragged
off and given a forcible reeducation in the
reason for the season.
There’s even the pitiful SCP-193x3, a fat,
sweaty, and perpetually drunk middle-aged
man in a Santa suit who has Irish cream for
blood.
Reminds me of my Uncle Frank.
But today, we’re dealing with something
REALLY special: A Christmas variety show hosted
by everyone’s favorite anomalous Foundation
researcher…
SCP-963!
Sorry, sorry, we mean Dr. Bright.
Dr. Bright is getting ready to receive guests
for his Christmas party like no other, and
the good news is, we’re all invited!
There’s going to be stories, songs, comedy,
and more cameos than you could shake a Yule
log at!
So get comfortable - It’s going to be a
fun one.
But first, a quick message from this episode’s
sponsors:
The fine folks at the Shark Punching Center,
the first and last line of defense between
us and those dark-eyed subaquatic menaces!
And of course, the latest giggletastic product
from our good pals at the Dr. Wondertainment
Toy Company, a perfect stocking filler for
the Christmas season.
That’s right - We’re talking about Spider
Party; just add water for eighty thousand
legs worth of arachnoFUNbia!
Warning: Parental supervision required.
Your definition of arachnofunbia may differ
from that used by Dr. Wondertainment.
Avoid use of this product if you are sensitive
to spider venom.
Not for use in households with pets or which
are situated on reclaimed toxic waste dumps
and/or Indian burial grounds.
Dr. Wondertainment is not responsible for
any cases of spideritis, spiderosis, or spidermania
caused by use of this product.
Not to be used for gambling purposes without
the express written consent of Dr. Wondertainment.
Oh, and of course, an additional thank you
to our friends at the Manna Charitable Foundation
for their generous grant!
More on that one later!
While Dr. Bright prepared for guests, SCP-1845
- a collection of freakishly intelligent animals
including a raccoon, a crow, a baby pig, a
chicken, and a fox by the name of King Eugenio
- prepared a dress rehearsal for a nativity
scene.
Conflict erupted when the Chicken kept flubbing
her lines, and the other cast members found
it strange that King Eugenio insisted on playing
the Baby Jesus himself.
By all accounts, he was kind of a nightmare
to work with thanks to his massive ego.
The situation worsened when SCP-329-J - a
floating YIELD sign that believes it’s a
ghost - turned up, claiming to be the Ghost
of Christmas Past, and started bothering King
Eugenio.
If you think this is weird, you’re going
to have real trouble with the rest of this,
so we recommend sitting back, putting your
feet up, and just rolling with it, cause it’s
only going to get stranger from here.
Anyway, back to the living room of Dr. Jack
Bright, who was singing a special SCP Foundation
parody of the Christmas carol “God Rest
Ye, Merry Gentlemen”, when the first set
of guests arrived.
It was Dr. Charles Odgen Gears, a famously
humorless Foundation Senior Researcher, dressed
in his own adorably gaudy Christmas attire.
But he wasn’t alone - He’d brought special
musical guests, Captain and Tennille,
the classic 1970s duo responsible for hits
such as “Love Will Keep Us Together” and
“Muskrat Love.”
They’d actually attended gigs like this
before, but thanks to the beauty of Class-A
Amnestics, it was all new to them.
Let’s ignore the murky ethical implications
of that and keep on trucking.
Next, this Christmas extravaganza careened
into another anomalous skit, this one featuring
SCP-1192 - A little boy named Timmy who was
somehow transformed into a bird - and Count
Rockula, a badass heavy metal aficionado summoned
by SCP-1987-J’s anomalously sick chord progression.
Timmy was naturally a little upset about being
trapped as a bird, and thus, he was unable
to spend Christmas with his family.
Count Rockula, being the Lord of Ultimate
Rockness, refused to let the poor bird/boy
suffer.
In order to cheer him up, he grabbed his guitar
and launched into a spirited rock and roll
Christmas carol, with much racier lyrics than
you’d probably expect from a wholesome Christmas
tune.
The Count was left feeling a little nervous
afterwards when Timmy started asking him what
a “camel toe” was.
The sooner we get away from this little disaster
of a segment, the better…
Back to Dr. Bright’s living room once more.
The good anomalous doctor has just finished
telling a hilarious anecdote to Dr. Gears
and 1970s music powerhouse Captain and Tenille,
when Dr. Gears took the opportunity to break
some bad news: A certain, very rowdy former
party guest had found out about this year’s
meet up, and he would likely be joining any
minute now, much to Bright’s dismay.
As if on cue, the door burst open, and there
stood SCP-076-2, also known as Able, the immortal
swordsman, wearing an ugly Christmas sweater
and a Santa hat, yelling “Did somebody say
par-taaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaay?”
Dr. Bright was mortified.
At last year’s party,
Able had gotten tanked on hard eggnog and
embarrassed them all in front of Country Music
Legend Willie Nelson with his antics.
Specifically, he’d stolen a local sleigh
and used it to run over Bright’s grandmother.
However, Able insisted that this time around,
he’d be well-behaved.
Only time would tell if that prediction held
any water.
He began to sing a personalized parody of
“Away In A Manger” in a grating falsetto
voice as an act of penance.
Let’s get away from those goofballs again
and hop over to another ace comedic duo: Lord
Blackwood and Wellington G. Wonderhorse.
Blackwood, also known as SCP-1867, is a telepathic
sea slug who believes he was once a galavanting
British noble and explorer.
And Wellington, also known as SCP-1156, is
a talking horse with a thick cockney accent
and a dapper woolen scarf and top hat.
This pair of talking creatures wished the
audience a very Merry Christmas, before engaging
in conversation.
However, this didn’t get very far, as Lord
Blackwood couldn’t understand Wellington’s
thick cockney accent.
When Lord Blackwood got too frustrated to
go on, he called Wellington a horse’s ass.
Everybody laughs.
Roll on snare drums.
Curtains.
Back to Dr. Bright’s increasingly chaotic
Christmas house party.
Able was already getting a little sloshed
and telling wild jokes, when another guest
appeared at the door.
When Dr. Bright answered, he saw Dr. Rights,
a female fellow researcher, standing there
in a full-body trench coat.
She expressed a desire to meet Dr. Bright
under the mistletoe, to which he replied,
“Rights, I didn't put up any mistletoe this
year.”
But Rights, obviously in the Christmas spirit,
with a smile on her face and with no concern
for the lack of mistletoe at the party, disrobed
from her trench coat.
Donned in her hand-knitted, wool Christmas
two-piece, she began to dance toward Dr. Bright
while singing a parody of the saucy Christmas
hit, “Santa Baby” -
Uhhhh….Let’s cut to another word from
one of our sponsors:
The wonderful folks at the Manna Charitable
Foundation, the world’s leading anomalous
charity group.
In this sponsorship break, Manna Charitable
Foundation representative Sally Struthers
placed a small mechanical contraption on a
table and said:
“This is the Christmas Miracle Maker.
Thanks to state-of-the-art terraforming technology,
this durable and easy-to-use device, once
activated, will induce rapid and aggressive
climate change in order to transform its surrounding
environment into a perfect snowy winter's
day just in time for a white Christmas.
The seed banks and genetic samples contained
within it will ensure that majestic evergreens
just right for decorating and reindeer perfect
for pulling a one-horse open sleigh will replace
all the local flora and fauna, and it can
even whip up a Christmas dinner with all the
trimmings for those souls in need!
Every one of your donations puts us one step
closer to our goal of manufacturing and airdropping
15,000 of these units across Africa in time
for Christmas Eve.
So please call in your pledge or write a check
today - and let them know it's Christmas time
again.”
Thank you, Sally.
Let’s get back to Dr. Bright’s party now
things are looking a little more Safe For
Work - If only slightly, at least.
Decorated Russian Mobile Task Force Operative
Agent Strelnikov had joined the party, and
was naturally beginning to make multiple jokes
about how much he hates Chechens, much to
the discomfort of everyone else in attendance.
The other party guests tried to make him discuss
literally anything else, but he refused, repeatedly
circling back to telling stories about Chechens.
He only broke from his diatribe to give a
rendition of the formerly popular Trololo
meme song, which he insisted was a traditional
Russian song of homecoming.
Back to King Eugenio the fox, who’d been
going through a parallel Christmas Carol narrative
this whole time during Dr. Bright’s story.
The talking Yield sign was his Spirit of Christmas
Past, and while we sadly missed his Spirit
of Christmas Present, as we join him before
his own gravestone, we can see that his Spirit
of Christmas Yet To Come was SCP-173 - The
Sculpture.
As The Sculpture pointed towards King Eugenio’s
grave in judgemental silence, Eugenio came
to terms with what a jerk he’d been.
When he was freed from this horrible fantasy,
he realized that he needed to change his ways,
and thankfully, there was still time.
Back to Dr. Bright’s Christmas Party, which
was in full swing.
However, Captain and Tennille, who had been
in charge of cooking the Christmas goose,
had made a terrible mistake.
They were told to run it through SCP-914 on
the Fine setting, which would create a wonderful
goose roast, but they instead ran it through
the Very Fine mode, turning it into a collection
of live goslings.
However, in the greatest hour of need, a hero
rose.
Dr. Clef appeared at the door, dressed as
Santa Claus, with enough delicious clam chowder
for everyone!
And as the party guests enjoyed their chowder,
even more guests arrived: King Eugenio, Wellington,
SCP-173, Lord Blackwood, the Ghostly Yield
Sign, Count Rockula, Timmy the Bird, and even
Sally Struthers, while the rest of the anomalous
animals formed a perfect nativity scene.
While Count Rockula performed a Rock and Roll
rendition of “Come All Ye Faithful”, Dr.
Bright was content that everyone here had
learned the true meaning of Christmas after
all.
Even King Eugenio had learned a lot about
being more kind and compassionate to his fellow
beasts.
With the help of Lord Blackwood, he obtained
SCP-662, The Butler’s Hand Bell, and used
it to summon Mr. Deeds, along with a delicious,
fully-cooked Christmas goose with all the
trimmings.
While Dr. Rights flirted with Able and the
other party guests prepared to enjoy their
chowder and goose, Dr. Bright wished everyone
a happy Christmas, with Timmy adding, “And
343 bless us, every one!”
We hope this little exploration into how the
Foundation celebrates Christmas has helped
your heart grow three sizes this day - and
not in the way it would if you ate a meal
off of SCP-807.
Stay tuned for A Keter Kinda Hanukkah and
A Keter Kinda Kwanza - Coming soon!
Now go check out “SCP-4666 - The Yule Man”
and “Alaska Doomsday Weapon SCP-804 - World
Without Man” for more snow-swept havoc from
the SCP Foundation!